so I'm just gonna strip now for YouTube
we're trying on ladies Halloween
costumes I like looking at them on women
but I do not want to see that on myself
I generally wear a lot of clothes on
Halloween it's normally a cold time of
year I'm so excited I don't stand by a
sexy fire woman only problem no firemen
in the [ __ ] world looks like this
could work this in a firehouse what am I
supposed to do with this I got to feel
what it's like but also don't break the
costume and voila kind of like sexy
firefighter meets Larry King these
suspenders are stupid I broke it I broke
it by touching it ah this might be the
dumbest costume I've ever seen I would
not want to trick-or-treating this
however the way this is cut it really
allows you like swing dem hips give the
girl some camp's pants gonna be creepy
sexy this is a nun I'm Jewish and I'm
offended not even real leather this is
ridiculous ly sexy backside this is not
what you want to see just like Oh that'd
be a very difference out of music I feel
like Batman hello from the depths of the
Catholic Church one hero emerged so I
have any problem with the sexual ization
of a nun none whatsoever
ladybugs aren't supposed to be sexy this
is lingerie isn't it this is just what
you would wear in the bedroom if you're
trying to really get buggy with it I've
never looked at a ladybug and thought
I'd hit that I would wear this I'd wear
this outfit for Halloween this is the
hairiest ladybug I've ever seen
this feels like the most accurate
representation of a bug
you look like I'm flying let alone lack
of fabric I just think this is just a
stupid costume don't like it look how
cute this is
it's dumb this is dumb I would feel very
exposed walking down the street like
this this is stupid
this is taking a depiction of a
seven-year-old and turning it sexy I
dressed up as a sexy baby once for
Halloween and this is by far worse not
gonna say it makes my biceps look better
but my leg looks like a Dexter victim
who's designing these clothes if you
want to look sexy I would never wear
this because you would just make people
think about Girl Scouts and Girl Scouts
shouldn't be selling those kind of
cookies I'm not happy
I have small breasts I feel like a woman
with real breasts is in danger and this
this feels gross on so many levels
what's like the most upsetting thing to
me though is like I knowing that like if
I saw someone wear this properly I'd be
like yeah it was pretty good you know I
came in here today
pretty Pro sexy costumes I'm a little
more torn now because I've never seen a
guy dressed up as a sexy ladybug because
that's stupid ladies you don't need to
do this there's a lot more sexiness when
people look like they put thought into
an outfit if you don't want to dress
sexy you do not have to dress sexy but
if you want to dress sexy might I
suggest the ladybug
[Music]